hey youtubers is Charlie the BBC totally
just released the official TV trailer
for the Doctor Who 50th anniversary
episode there was some drama surrounding
a leak of the trailer I'll talk about
that but mostly we need to talk about
our top 10 moments as if there are only
10 I'm also doing a bunch more videos
with BBC and Nerdist for the 50th
anniversary be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos I'll have information
in the description about that too but
it's top 10 time so number 10 the Dalek
fleet during the time war we've seen
Dalek fleets and Cybermen fleets and
episodes like a good man goes to war and
asylum of the Daleks but we'd never seen
them during the time war this is a lot
like the opening scene in Star Wars
Episode three where they basically just
zoomed in and out of this mega fleet so
it's gonna be epic number 9 the Fez the
doctor has always had a really special
relationship with his neck where an hats
but I feel like the Fez is one of the
most famous hats that the doctor has
ever worn number 8 Matt Smith flying
around London outside of the TARDIS
there's actually some behind-the-scenes
images from when they shot this it's
basically his first moment as the 11th
doctor so it's a big callback to that
episode number 7 the Zygons so unless
you're a big fan of classic ooh or if
you watched a lot of old episodes you'll
really be seeing the Zygons for the
first time they've been referenced in
more recent episodes but they made their
premiere during the fourth doctor's run
Tom Baker and terror of the Zygons if
you remember the official images the BBC
has been posting of the 50th anniversary
there's actually an image with a woman
wearing Tom Baker scarf that's basically
Beverley Christmas she's playing a young
version of the Kate Stewart character
it's also real a nice callback to Tom
Baker's doctor once the dentally David
Tennant has said that the Zygons are
actually his favourite Doctor Who
monster of all time this probably just a
coincidence that they're in here then
but that leads me to number 6 number 6
David Tennant in his TARDIS there are
actually three unique TARDIS's in the
episode and there's still a lot of
theories about which version of 10 David
Tennant is playing but currently the
leading theory is 10 - number 5 David
Tennant riding a horse out of his TARDIS
the amazingness of this is totally
self-explanatory number 4 Rose Tyler is
the bad wolf entity the glowy eyes let
us know that she was going to be doing
something very serious one esque when
she was in super goddess form leaving
clues for everyone she also has a line
in the trailer that will be part of my
top three moments but I'll talk about
that in a second all of my top three
moments are John Hurt moments obviously
he is basically at the center of this
episode so number 3 John Hurt
gallifrey we've seen Gallifrey in
previous episodes but because this
episode is just so cinematic and is done
in such a big way it's gonna be so much
more epic than the depictions we've seen
of it previously number 2 the giant red
button one of the great things about a
giant red button is is that no matter
what language you speak or what country
you live in there's nothing like a giant
red button that screams don't push me
which of course in the Doctor Who world
means you totally have to push it right
now the leading theory is is that this
is actually part of the moment or the
moment itself Rose Tyler has a line in
the trailer where she says the moment is
coming so I'm guessing that this is what
she's talking about
we can totally debate this in the
comments but we're gonna get a couple
more clips of the 50th anniversary
before the episode premieres so we
should all be looking for the key for
Cillian and my number one moment John
Hurt's TARDIS even people who have no
understanding of Doctor Who and don't
really know what the story is know that
the blue box represents Doctor Who no
matter what language you speak or where
you live it is so universal this symbol
of the TARDIS so anytime we get to see a
new TARDIS
it's an event of the highest order
obviously the next event like this will
be when we get to see Peter Capaldi's
TARDIS I'll be doing a separate video
for that be sure to subscribe to get it
but let me know what your favorite
moments from the trailer were and do you
think that John Hurt will be using the
moment in the episode and what do Queen
Elizabeth's credentials have to do with
bringing the three doctors together if
you didn't see it before I posted a
video earlier this week explaining a lot
of the videos that I'll be doing with
Nerdist in the BBC around the 50th
anniversary episode there's also special
livestream coming there's a link in the
description to all that stuff like I
said earlier this trailer actually
leaked early on Friday originally the
BBC was going to post it on television
but it was sent to BBC Spain who posted
it to their Facebook page it was taken
down but of course not before a thousand
people ripped it and uploaded it to
YouTube so the BBC naturally just posted
this early I'm sure somewhere Steven
Moffat is screaming just a little bit
next week on November 15th the BBC will
be airing its next 50th anniversary clip
during the children need special I have
information about that right here you
can click to find out and you can click
here to get all my other Doctor Who 50th
anniversary videos thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow for
Walking Dead high-fives
you